>>FERNANDEZ: Hi and welcome to Android Developer
Office Hours.
I'm Joe Fernandez from Android Developer Relations.
And this week, we're going to talk about making
Android applications accessible.
I'm joined by a guest from our Google accessibility
team.
We have T.V. Raman to my left, Casey Burkhardt
and Alan Viverette.
Under the table who you can't see is Tilden,
Raman's guide dog who is being very fluffy
and cute, but won't be speaking today.
We're going to do things a little bit different
today because we're focusing on accessibility.
We're going to really just talk about those
issues.
Casey and Alan are going to talk about or
have some material to present.
And at the end we'll take some more questions
on accessibility and if you don't have accessibility
questions don't worry about it.
Next week, we'll make sure to cover those
things as well.
So with that I'll introduce Raman.
>> RAMAN: Thank you Joe.
Welcome everyone to the session on Android
accessibility.
My name is T.V. Raman, I lead accessibility
affairs for Android and Chrome.
And with me I have two engineers from team
Casey and Alan.
To give you a brief overview slash intro of
what we are talking about today.
So, as developers when you step back and look
at Android, the platform, what does Android
give you?
Android basically makes it easy for you to
focus on your application as opposed to worrying
about different devices, different screen
sizes.
Somebody has a keyboard, somebody doesn’t
have a keyboard.
You focus on your application.
That's really the core thing that the Android
platform provides for you.
And so you can write your application and
have it running on hundreds of millions of
different devices.
What we from accessibility do is we broadened
this focus even more.
So we just talk about different devices, but
people are different too.
Some of your users might be able to see a
little less than others.
Some of your users might need a slightly different
color scheme.
Some of them might need larger text.
Some of them may not see at all and may need
spoken approach.
Some of your users may need specific affordances.
So, accessibility is then about increasing
and significantly increasing the size of the
user base of your applications.
And writing applications that are really cool
that work in a lot different user scenarios.
I myself work on applications that are relevant
to blind users.
And I describe it as working for the eyes
free user context.
So, don't think about the user not being able
to see, think about the user not looking at
the screen.
So, that's the broad thrust of accessibility.
And what we've been working on as part of
the Android accessibility affair is to build
the right set of APIs into the platform so
that you as a developer can focus on what
you do best and what you enjoy which is writing
your application.
I'll give you a brief overview of how Android
accessibility works.
We gave a detailed talk at Google I/O this
year and you can watch that talk and it's
entirety on YouTube.
But essentially, Android accessibility is
something we started working on in 2008 and
originally shipped as part of Donut in 2009,
and we've come a long way since.
A typical way a blind user interacts with
your application is by navigating through
your app and getting spoken feedback, auditory
feedback for the item that's in focus.
As of Jellybean we were--also added Braille
support that is in beta.
But what happens then is that a blind user
is essentially navigating your application
item at a time, control at a time, getting
spoken feedback.
And so over the years, we've introduced better
and better user level affordances for doing
this.
What this all looks like in Jellybean is that
the user navigates using a combination of
[INDISTINCT] one is that of touch exploration,
where the user can touch different parts of
the screen and has appropriate feedback for
what you're touching.
And that sort of gives you random access to
all parts of your display.
Random access because it's great, it's--yeah,
or the one complexity if you're developer
right?
You can get to anything with the same level
of effort.
Its problem it's random.
So, what we also added in Jellybean was with
the ability to what we call leniently navigate
the interface, which then gives you a more
deterministic access to different aspects
of your app.
And in practice as an end-user and a user
I use both.
So, I'll pull up an app, approximately know
that the search pattern is on the top right.
I'll go touch there and if I don't here the
search pattern, I'll flick left or right from
there and arrive at the search pattern and
then double tap.
How all of this works in the framework is
through three concepts that Casey and Alan
will explain to you in a lot more detail.
There is a notion called accessibility focus
in the system which is implemented along side
system focus with the difference that everything
in the user interface can get accessibility
focus.
And as accessibility focus moves, our accessibility
services like TalkBack, SpeakIt or BrailleBack,
brailles it out on a Braille display.
So now you have accessibility focus.
As I said when you touch, your accessibility
focus lands on that spot.
But you can also navigate with gestures and
Alan will show you those during the demo as
we go through this, and we call those accessibility
gestures.
Now, we are computer scientist, so--and all
computer scientist do things by introducing
a level of indirection.
And so what we do in Android API is that the
accessibility gestures actually invoke accessibility
actions.
And it's those actions that actually perform
user actions.
And those actually makes for a level of flexibility
because then in the--in a--you can actually
build more innovative user interfaces for
people with motor impairments and things like
that where you can then trigger these accessibility
actions throughout their affordances.
So the goal as I said of the accessibility
API is to work behind the covers and just
make your applications work.
And that's pretty much true of you use built-in
Android user interface controls and do all--everything
right.
But then as you step out of that box, as you
start becoming inventive, as you write custom
controls then you have to give the API and
the framework a little bit of help.
And it's fairly those aspects that these 30
and 40 minutes will be spent on.
Allan and Casey will show you a sequence of
demos, and show you how these can be fixed.
There is a sample app to go with this and
we can point you at the source code to this
later during the talk.
So, Alan and Casey, take it away.
>> BURKHARDT: Thanks Raman.
So as Raman mentioned, there's accessibility
APIs on Android.
We've had them since Donut.
In Ice Cream Sandwich, we introduced the new
concept, the new feature "Explore by Touch"
which will ask a blind user to touch the screen
and have the contact that's being touched
spoken to them.
So the way that this works is when you the
user actually touches a control, the Android
Framework takes that control, bundles it in
a nice package, sends it through the accessibility
API to any accessibility services that might
be listening.
An accessibility service is--an example of
one is TalkBack, that software that Alan and
I write.
We basically intercept these accessibility
events that the framework sends, take the
data out of them, explore the view hierarchy
of an application and provide spoken and other
auditory and haptic feedback to the blind
user to make the application and the device
accessible.
Alan actually is going to turn the device
on now and show you what TalkBack looks like
the first time.
Booting up here.
>> VIVERETTE: All right.
So one of the really great things about the
accessibility service is that, as a developer
you don't have to worry that much about it.
So as Raman mentioned, if you use standard
widgets, things just work.
So, we're going to turn on TalkBack first.
So we're going to all apps, settings.
And down here at the bottom we have accessibility.
And one of the services is TalkBack.
So, we'll turn that on.
There's a switch over the top that you can't
see.
So this dialog pops up explaining that TalkBack
sees basically everything that is shown to
the user, so all of the text that's on-screen,
TalkBack has access to.
So we'll just click okay.
It's okay that TalkBack can interact with
things the way that the user would.
>> BURKHARDT: So as TalkBack is turned on,
you see certain items on the screen receive
a yellow highlight.
In Jellybean, this represents accessibility
focus.
So as Raman mentioned accessibility focus
works just like system focus, except any item
whether it's system focused or not can receive
it.
So that the accessibility service can interrogate
it and find more--find out more information
about it.
So, as Alan moves his finger around the screen
you'll see the different items receive accessibility
focus.
TalkBack receives events regarding that change
in focus and speaks to the user to let them
know what they touched.
In Jellybean there's also the concept of navigation
in a linear way.
So Alan can use a gesture from swiping left
to right or top to bottom to move focus through
the user interface.
>> VIVERETTE: So, we'll move out to the launcher
where it's at, a little bit more interesting.
So…
>> VIVERETTE: Touch home.
Double tap to activate it.
And now I can just swipe left and right to
move through items on the home screen.
So I'll swipe right a couple times.
So down here at the bottom we have all apps.
And then one app that we're going to be using
for demos later on is.
>> BURKHARDT: So in addition to exploring
by touch you can use gestures to navigate
linearly really though the UI.
In Jelly Bean we've also added gestures associated
with that accessibility actions.
So for example I only can do a two part swipe
up and then right and that will perform the
system action of pulling down the notification
shade.
>> VIVERETTE: So, I'll just go up, right.
>> BURKHARDT: So and then Alan can swipe down
on left and that will dismiss the notification
as if he pressed the back button.
>> VIVERETTE: So I'll do down and left to
do a back action.
>> BURKHARDT: So we have a couple of other
system gestures as well.
So and what's also worth mentioning is from
Ice Cream Sandwich and on, accessibility services
when they receive one of these events can
interrogate the view hierarchy.
So TalkBack for example can deep dive into
the views your applications presents and get
more information about them such as whether
a button is clickable, a view is checkable
and so forth.
So this is used throughout TalkBack.
So now we're actually going to cover it at
the top three problems that we see most often
in a third party developer applications.
We have a sample app which we're going to
use to sort of get into this issues and illustrate
them for you.
>> VIVERETTE: And I'll double tap to launch
that.
Okay.
And so Casey is going to take us through the
inaccessible content description's app.
So this is a very common mistake that we see.
>> Actually Casey, we're getting a rustled
from your mic, could you just make sure that
it's not touching your t-shirt too much.
>> BURKHARDT: I think I've lost my mic.
That's interesting.
>> You can run it up the outside of your shirt,
you know, once you find it.
>> BURKHARDT: Sure, why don't you do that.
>> VIVERETTE: Sure, all right.
So I'll just take us through the inaccessible
versions of the content description now.
All right.
So one of the first things that we see is
this edit box and there's an icon in the top
left of the screen here that has a little
search icon.
And since I only hear edit box I don't know
that the meaning of this edit box is so let's
say a search turn.
So swiping through the rest of the interface.
That's pretty clear.
Now, Image 76 isn't the best description for
this if you can see it there's a little map
here.
So as a sighted user I can guess, "Okay this
is probably has something to do with location."
But because there is no text attached to it
to the accessibility service, I don't know
what's going on.
So I'll continue to use swipe through.
And we have the same unlabeled images here.
So let's take a step back and look at some
of the ways that we can fix this.
So we'll.
Back out of the keyboard and it will back
out of.
This particular demo and open up the fix version.
>> BURKHARDT: So you could see in this--in
this edit box, look at this edit text the
one that we have now.
There's actually hint text and since TalkBack
and other accessibility services can get information
about the view hierarchy it can pull out information
from the accessibility event end from your
view to learn what the hint text is.
So now when I navigate to.
I hear the hint text which gives me more context
than to what I'm actually doing as a user
and as I moved through the user interface.
I get the go button and now we've added content
descriptions to this image buttons so when
I navigate to them.
Local deals.
Social deals.
And real time deals rather than hearing image
91, image 76.
>> VIVERETTE: So as a developer this is one
of the easiest things that you can fix.
You simply go into your layout XML, you go
to each items.
So you go to your image view or your image
button and you add an Android:contentDescription.
And if you have things that you specifically
don't want to have a content description you'll
notice that you still get link errors if you
put no descriptions.
You'll get this little yellow squeals in your
layout XML.
So if there's some thing like there's a little
star here that were purely using as decoration
there is no reason that a user needs to know
that it's a star, we simply put content description
equals at null.
So that null let's it know that you thought
about whether or not your image needs to content
description and you decided that because it's
purely decorative it's okay to be skipped.
For things that have dynamic content descriptions
you can also call view.set contentDescription
so if the meaning of.
Is going to change sometime during the execution
of the application.
I'll simply call whatever variable I have
to store that in .set contentDescription and
pass it to the new explanation of what that
button does.
>> BURKHARDT: We'd also like to mention that
we prefer that you would not override to get
contentDescription up on the view class.
Avoid taking that shortcut because we do some
caching once that contentDescription is called
and it helps us out and make sure that your
users can get the correct description of that
button when they need to, so.
>> VIVERETTE: Always use set contentDescription
if you're setting your contentDescription
dynamically.
All right.
So let's back out of this.
And one other thing to take note here is that
each of this buttons is totally accessible
in Ice Cream Sandwich.
A lot of developers are going to be developing
for let's say Gingerbread or below and on
these devices accessibility relies on use
of a track ball or directional pad on a hardware
keyboard.
So each of these buttons is also set to be
Android focusable equals true which means
if a user has a keyboard and they start pressing
down or right, they'll move from this icon
to this icon, to this icon.
Buttons and image buttons are going to have
this set by default but if you use an image
view you'll have to explicitly say this image
view should be able to receive keyboard focus.
All right.
So let's move on to one of the next things
which is grouping and ordering of items.
>> BURKHARDT: So as we move to this user interface
we see that we have some header text and we
have a table with some data in it.
Let's jump right in to the table.
And you see as I--as I navigate through this
UI and when I touch the table, I'm not actually
getting any kind of feedback, I have to go
over and touch the actual item over here.
And as I swipe left and right through the
UI I'm getting--I'm getting very granular
information.
And also if I touch the table as a whole it's
going to read all of this content which is
hard to follow.
What we need to improve here is the way that
user grouped so that the user can access the
information in an individual way so they don't
have to get this large verse of text.
>> VIVERETTE: So what TalkBalk sees when you
open up this application is a bunch of text.
So these are all--all of these items here
are actually just thrown into a relative layout,
so date is below from status is below date.
To TalkBack this just looks like a big bag
of text we use.
So what it reads is a big bag of text we use
in order on--of the screen left or right and
top to bottom which is nice if you want to
spend 12 minutes listing to the screen but.
>> BURKHARDT: If we go in to the fix version.
We've now put all of this text we use that
are in relevant layout in their own individual
groupings, you know, hierarchal way--hierarchal
way that makes sense.
So now when I touch explore.
That's exactly what I want to hear.
One row in the table.
So the user can explore each one of these
rows one by one without having to hear the
full text in the entire table.
>> VIVERETTE: In our lab what we've actually
done is provide a little bit more context.
So amount here is actually inside of a linear--a
relative layout inside of a linear layout
that contains each of these rows.
And we've also for keyboard accessibility
made this row focusable.
So that let's TalkBack know that the things
inside of that layout should be grouped together.
One thing you'll also notice is when I go
to this top bar right here which starts out
with payment process in the top left and moves
into the description of this deal at the bottom.
It actually reads the title, the description
and then it reads the notes payment process
and the date.
The reason that we've done this is because
visually this information at the top, local,
social, real time deals, this title is larger,
it's more important--it's more immediate for
the user.
This description is also is more immediate.
If the user wants to hear more about it they
just stay on it for a little longer, they
hear what the status and the date are.
And the way that this actually works in code
is that we've set the content description
of this entire group.
So we've taken this relative layout and done
set contentDescription to be the text of each
of these items can concatenated in the order
that we want them red.
So when I tap on it.
So you'll hear those in the order that you
really want to hear them for efficiency.
>> BURKHARDT: That's right.
Okay.
Our last demo here deals with using custom
views.
So what we have here is a part of an application
that is just directly drawn.
We've basically implemented the onDraw method.
We have several objects and we call each of
those objects onDraw within the context of
the lager canvas, we draw directly to the
screen.
When TalkBack is on--because there's no textural
content actually associated with this view,
it's completely dead.
There's no touch exploration.
There's no feedback, nothing.
The application action bar will speak.
Because it's a standard Android action bar
but nothing else will.
The way we fix this, we have APIs in Jellybean
that allow for developers to use custom drawn
views and make them accessible.
We also have a helper class available.
Touch exploration helper which is available
in the Eyes-Free website.
Will point to the source for that shortly.
And now that I've implemented this node provider,
this new Jellybean API that allows us to define
regions in custom views for things, I can
touch explore the content.
I can also double tap to make things happen.
And I can even do something like long pressing.
The text color is now red disabled.
So this is basically the mechanism in Jellybean
that allows developers to make their entirely
custom drawn views accessible to the standard
Jellybean accessibility sources.
>> VIVERETTE: So if you're rendering something
in OpenGL which is great and pretty and fast,
you can also make it totally accessible.
And so this requires a little bit more work.
We've made this node provider helper class
to make it a little bit easier but you can
provide an entire view hierarchy virtually
that TalkBack and a user of accessibility
will be able to explore.
So actually I'd like to swipe through this
too, jus to show.
When you implement the node provider you sort
of magically get a lot of extra features.
So I can swipe left and right through this.
And that didn't take any extra effort.
Just adding those virtual nodes, lets TalkBack
manage swiping left and right through the
hierarchy.
So one thing that we didn't mention earlier--I
would like to back out for a real quick.
So you'll notice that on this tablet everything
is really small.
And for somebody with low vision.
They find that things in your app are a little
difficult to see.
So one way to get around that.
And I'll pop into accessibilities settings.
It's the internal feature called large text
mode.
So this is going to do exactly what you expected
to.
So for anybody on the Hangout or for anybody
watching in maybe low resolution you can hopefully
read the text now.
It's a lot bigger.
And one really easy mistake to make is in
your application, when you're setting your
text sizes to use density independent pixels,
dips instead of scaled pixels.
So when you set text size, if you use scale
pixels it respects the system's desired text
size.
One thing that this can be a problem for is
if you don't test your app with slightly larger
text or slightly longer strings, you may find
that strings extend of the edge of the screen
or wrap in ways that you don't expect.
If you're doing internationalization of your
apps, it's important to make sure that you're
testing for this any way.
So if you have a string that shows up as a
certain size, in Germany it may end up being
longer and with large fonts on, it's going
to be loner as well as a little bit taller.
So it's important to test your app with that
to make sure it works but generally if you
use scaled pixels instead of dips whit will
just work.
So let's go in to one of the test apps real
quick to see what the difference looks like.
So we'll pop into the inaccessible version
of item grouping.
>> BURKHARDT: Uh-hmm.
>> Item grouping inaccessible.
>> BURKHARDT: And we'll see that the text
size was exactly the same which we're looking
at here is the header.
It's the same as it was previously because
we've actually constructed this view using
dips rather than scaled pixels.
And if we go back to out into the fixed version
you can see that the header now is quite large
and it follows the convention of a platform
by using scaled pixels so the text is larger
for users of a large text feature.
>> VIVERETTE: And you'll also notice that
the text which used to take up only line is
now wrapped on two.
And fortunately that doesn't mess up the rest
of our view.
It works very well if the line needs to wrap
again.
All right.
So some of the other features that we're just
going to cover real quick, but we're not going
to do specific demos for.
Our web accessibility, so Android Ice Cream
Sandwich and Jellybean have support for opening
web view content and touch exploring.
So a lot of apps are hybrid.
You have both of web view and native Android
content.
And if you go into accessibility options and
turn on TalkBack you should also make sure--I'll
just pop in there again.
Actually I'm going to use the recent apps
swipe to get in there.
So we'll do down right.
I'll swipe over to settings, so that's just
going to be a couple of swipes to the right.
All right.
Settings, and I'll double tap to open that
up.
Okay.
And I'm just going to go straight to accessibilities
since it's.
Is located near the bottom.
And you'll notice this item, Enhance Web Accessibility.
When I double click that it gets a little
bit more obvious.
So what this means is that when this feature
is turned on, web views that has JavaScript
are going to inject something called AndroidVox.
This is similar to ChromeVox which is our
web accessibility solution on chrome.
It's a--basically a JavaScript screen reader.
And it allows users to touch your web view
content and receive touch exploration feedback
the same way that they want for a needed Android
views.
This also works for swiping left and right.
So if you have a hybrid web app--this feature
is turned on by default when you do setup
wizard accessibility for a new device.
If you turned on TalkBack afterwards, you'll
have to make sure to turn this on.
So I'm just going to allow this.
And now when I have web content and I'm testing
my application for accessibility.
I can swipe through normal Android content
and then it will automatically start moving
into my web content when I get to that.
>> BURKHARDT: And our recommendation for developers,
you have hybrid apps or web apps, are basically
to use your stand--web accessibility standards,
the W3C accessibility standards within your
hybrid app web views to make sure that your
contact is accessible.
So use ARIA live regions, label your images
with default tags those standard web accessibility
recommendations.
>> VIVERETTE: And the same [INDISTINCT] arts
apply for all text.
So if you have decorate images--decorative
images, they--if they don't need content descriptions
for native Android they wouldn't need old
text for web content.
>> RAMAN: They do all the [INDISTINCT] empty
strains, some [INDISTINCT] along side--on
the Android side which is all [INDISTINCT]
>> VIVERETTE: All right.
So that's a quick overview of all of the features
in Android accessibility.
We haven't covered Braille.
We don't have a Braille device with us right
now to demo but for making sure that your
app works with Braille you can actually typically
just swipe through.
If you can swipe through and you can double
click to activate things in your app and everything
is red as you would expect then your apps
should work very well for a user with a Braille
input/output device
>> RAMAN: And as I mentioned a new--a Google
IO Talk from Google IO of 2012, this year
has more details on what we launched in relieving
in that also it does includes a Braille demo.
But I think of a Braille device as both as
an input and output device which is what it
actually is.
It's a Bluetooth device that both apps as
a Braille keyboard that allows a blind user
to input text and then also displays extra
component.
It's a very cool thing to see.
You can look at it at the in the YouTube videos
and but as developer you know, you shouldn't
have to worry about Braille versus speech
or do you need to be worrying about populating
this accessibility events correctly so that
the services can pick up the right observations.
>> VIVERETTE: So, as a developer there are
a lot of resources at your disposal for implementing
accessibility.
We have a great developer guideline section
on the Android website regarding accessibility.
We have great UX guidelines regarding accessibility
on the Android site.
TalkBack is open source, so if you need to
know a lot, you can actually check that out
online.
And the sample app that we ran through with
a bad and good versions of accessibility in
applications is also open sourced and available
online.
>> BURKHARDT: With that, I think we'll head
it back for questions.
>> Actually, we--and actually we have Richard
on the Hangout.
I'm going to put him on.
So he can ask you guys a question.
>> VIVERETTE: Sure.
>> Just wait one second.
Richard, can you hear us?
Oops, that's me.
>> BURKHARDT: We don't hear a thing.
>> One more time.
I'm sorry about that.
There's a--hold on.
>> VIVERETTE: We're working on hearing you.
>> Yeah.
Give me one second.
I'm going to sort this sound issue out real
quick.
>> I'm going to mess around a little bit with
our sound equipment.
Sorry, hold on a sec.
>> RAMAN: So, yeah, while we--while we get
the audio issue sorted here, [INDISTINCT]
I mean, this--it look--we look forward to
using you apps on [INDISTINCT] devices but
they know user interfaces.
There's a fun stuff to do in.
You'll probably discover in the process of
making your apps when accessible, that there
are simple user issues that you discover that
make your app more usable for all your users
as you fix these things.
>> VIVERETTE: And I think one of the most
important things in making an app accessible
is making sure that it's orderly and simplified.
Simplification is good for everyone.
So if it doesn’t take 15 button clicks to
get from one place to another, everyone wins.
>> BURKHARDT: Absolutely.
>> RAMAN: Enumerate the number of exclusive
actions that your users need to do, eliminate
the explicit pieces of content that users
half to read in order to figure out how to
use your application and, you know, things
that are sure stoppers for blind users that
usually are a pain in the neck for your avid
users, who don’t want to complain about
it.
But as we sort of smoothen those things out
the over all interaction gets a lot smaller.
And these are modern than devices right?
These are devices we use on the go.
The fastest somebody can do something on your
application, the more often they are like
to do it.
>> BURKHARDT: And the best way to test for
this stuff is the developer is testing by
doing.
So go and--go ahead into accessibility settings
and turn on TalkBack.
And go into your application; try to explore
it by touch.
Try to swipe through your user interface.
>> VIVERETTE: And close your eyes and keep
them closed.
>> BURKHARDT: Absolutely, no cheating.
>> All right, I think Richard's maybe working.
Richard, can you give it another shot please?
No, nothing.
>> RAMAN: No way.
>> BURKHARDT: Interesting.
>> RAMAN: Richard, can you do sign language?
Maybe we can read sign language.
>> All right.
Sorry guys.
I'm going to just go ahead and read Richard's
question now from the--from the Hangout.
Sorry about that Richard.
We'll--I'll get that question read for you.
So Richard's question is--let me just scroll
up.
He's curious about the performance hits that
a lot of the features that we implemented
on, I mean, you have on the device.
>> VIVERETTE: Yeah.
>> And how you run that?
>> RAMAN: So, the simple answer is their zero
performance, I hope so.
And let me answer that in the different level
in which does I believe it stands [INDISTINCT]
and then I let Allan and Casey fill in.
So, on the Android platform, the accessibility
API are present in every device.
So any Jellybean device has already the API
any Ice Cream Sandwich device has all these
APIs.
They don’t--they are on off until an accessibility
service is turned on.
So, until an accessibility service is turned
on, these--as I said, these APIs are not.
When an accessibility service is turned on,
these APIs raised to appropriate event and
they grow--go across by [INDISTINCT] but we've
spend a lot of time optimizing the single
framework.
So the performance that you see on the device
both in terms of load as well as battery is
almost zero.
Extra speech does take up some CPU cycles
but on to these devices, you don’t notice.
>> BURKHARDT: We have a lot of developers
who ask us often, "Is there a way we can only
implement some accessibility features and
turn them on if accessibility itself is on?"
And that’s something that you can do through
the accessibility manager class there is a
check to see if accessibility--if an accessibility
service is on and if explore touch is enabled.
>> VIVERETTE: Yeah.
So if you're using the accessibility helper
class, and you're creating a virtual view
hierarchy for all of your nodes, you can do
this only when accessibility is turned on
and that’s really easy to check.
Its accessibility manager dot is enabled and
I Touch Exploration enabled on newer devices,
newer APIs.
In terms of the performance hit that your
application takes, as Raman had mentioned
there really in none and we care very deeply
about performance.
I think tens of milliseconds is really pushing
it as far as the performance hit that somebody
has to deal with when accessibility is turned
on.
So we worked on profiling and making sure
that we're as fast as possible.
>> RAMAN: So you should take the fact that
we [INDISTINCT] these API's on every device,
as oppose to saying there's should be on some
devices that they user ask for accessibility
[INDISTINCT].
>> Okay.
>> So Richard is also one of...
>> Did sound--did sound start working yet?
>> ...especially on the battery.
>> RAMAN: Back of the [INDISTINCT] I use my
device everyday.
It talks to me with the whole time.
And I don’t find myself charging my phones
any more often than any of these guys.
So I typically leave home around 7:30 in the
morning.
I unplug my phone and I typically don’t
need to charge my phone until about 8:30 in
the evening.
So--and I use my phone a lot.
>> VIVERETTE: I also use my phone a lot.
I think I may actually get worse battery time
than Raman because I have my screen brightness
set a lot higher.
So that--I think that’s actually one of
the most interesting things is that while
we are doing speech in the background, we're
doing vibration in the background.
If the user just turns their brightness down,
they're probably going to save more battery
than they're eating up from the vibration,
the haptic feedback.
>> RAMAN: Alan wrote me a wonderful application
called shapes that actually it makes my screen
completely dark to which, it's the tone of
the dark.
>> VIVERETTE: Yeah, so all LED devices, he's
saving a lot of battery on screen brightness.
>> RAMAN: I do that on my laptops too.
My little, you know, laptop gives me about
six to eight hours so, it's a good thing.
Turn your monitor off, use speech.
>> FERNANDEZ: It's a challenge for the rest
of us today as supposed so trying to turn
your monitors off [INDISTINCT] with out them.
>> The other one was adjusting the brightness.
>> FERNANDEZ: [INDISTINCT] yeah, okay.
Let's see.
I actually thought I'd ask you guys a question.
You mentioned accessibility for web use.
>> VIVERETTE: Uh-hmm.
>> FERNANDEZ: And that feature in now in Ice
Cream Sandwich and also in Jellybean.
>> RAMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> FERNANDEZ: What's your advice for folks
who want to try to support that the--well,
for releases prior to Ice Cream Sandwich and
before?
>> RAMAN: So, actually the web view access
with also then in Honeycomb which is [INDISTINCT].
We're looking at Gingerbread devices, if you
have a--if you have an application, that's
a hybrid application and you want to support
accessibility for web use, you could do what
our Gmail team did.
And what they did was to take the [INDISTINCT]
so the [INDISTINCT] as Alan explained is a
JavaScript reader, an accessibility to looking
inside the [INDISTINCT] And what happens on
Ice Cream Sandwich--Honeycomb, Ice Cream Sandwich
and above is that the Android framework, when
the accessibility is enabled and that option
is turned on.
It actually adds a little piece of code that
injects that script into every webpage.
So the script is downloaded once, cached on
your device and then injected into HTML pages
as I say lower by adding a [INDISTINCT].
So if you have a specific application, as
an app is Gmail.
What the Gmail team did was going all the
way back to Froyo.
They took our script and added a little piece
of code in their web view handler that on
load, basically added a script back that injected
a script and then that’s actually how Gmail
talks on both Froyo and Gingerbread.
So, if you are a developer who's going to
hybrid app and you want to support all the
way back to Froyo that's what you need to
know.
>> VIVERETTE: So, if you're looking into doing
this yourself, you can actually check out
the web view source code on the Android project
site.
Look for accessibility and you'll find all
of the places where we're getting the URL
for the accessibility scripts, injecting it,
proving Java bridge API to JavaScript and
you can add that to your own web view, being
careful to not turn that on, on Honeycomb
and above because it's already being injected,
you don’t want it twice.
>> RAMAN: And once you do that, the service
that are serving that script app have a caching
policy [INDISTINCT] at least.
So you just use [INDISTINCT] you got it?
Between the device and server, they'll negotiate
appropriately and data script when, you know,
every few weeks based on the caching policies.
So you don’t have to worry about taking
a download on [INDISTINCT].
>> BURKHARDT: And also, if you're concerned
about performance, it's around the injection,
you can again check accessibility manager
to see if an accessibility services is active
on a device.
>> VIVERETTE: Yeah, that’s super important.
You don’t want to inject the script if accessibility
is off because then everybody will get Touch
Exploration and it will talk and that would
be weird.
>> FERNANDEZ: [INDISTINCT] great, thanks for
that very comprehensive answer guys.
Is there any more questions from him or...
>> Yeah.
Richard also wants to know if there's a way
to change the voice parameters.
I think he is referring to maybe using a different
voice and explain for confirmation.
>> FERNANDEZ: Different voices?
>> VIVERETTE: This is my favorite thing about
Android.
>> RAMAN: Oh, you want to answer that Alan?
Go for it.
>> VIVERETTE: Sure.
Let's--we'll all--I think we've all sort of
had an experience with this.
>> BURKHARDT: Yes.
>> VIVERETTE: So I personally use an Australian
voice on my phone, a female Australian voice.
It sounds really great for driving directions.
But one of the cool things about Android is
anyone can write a text-to-speech engine.
So if you go on a Play Store and look for
text-to-speech, there are a lot of engines
that you can download for like three or four
dollars and you get great quality voices.
These are drop-in replacements, so if somebody
installs a German voice and their device look--is
set to German, it will just speak; it will
speak everything in German correctly.
And we have translations and TalkBack for
all of the languages that are available for
TTS on Android.
>> BURKHARDT: And also as far as changing
voice parameters, TalkBack will respect whatever
is currently set in text-to-speech settings.
So if you prefer voice faster, you can set
the voice speed to very fast.
TalkBack will use that and send all the device
feedback in a very fast manner.
>> RAMAN: So for us, when we design that with
extra speed API.
We had a couple of adding principles which
is we wanted users to be able to get other
voices and have all their talking applications
talk with that better voice with TalkBack
or other applications.
All right.
So, let's say somebody has written you an
app that reads a doc.
You get a better voice as a user you should
be able to use that voice for that other app.
So, why is that an app is so multi?
And that actually creates for a good ecosystem
because if you are a developer who's writing
an application that talks, you can focus on
writing an application and be assured that
when a user gets a better voice your app sounds
better.
All right.
Just as if I download your app--if I buy your
app today and then I use it on the phone with
a better display, it looks better.
All right.
So, similarly if I--you do download your app
today and I get a voice that sounds better
on your app.
>> Could you hear that?
>> RAMAN: And that's actually how this whole
thing is about.
So, excellent question and it shows up another
aspect of the platform that's interesting
and...
>> Just a couple in YouTube.
I'm sorry.
>> FERNANDEZ: We have some questions in the
YouTube stream which I'm not sure I can find.
Maybe you can read them out for us Daniel.
>> Yeah.
So, the one I found is from Funnergoat.
Quiz question is any tips regarding accessibility
in app widgets?
What type of app widgets do target users get
the most use out of?
>> RAMAN: So, speaking for myself as a user,
app widgets that, you know, display a subset
piece of information are very, very useful.
So, I'll highlight vote app for just that
I find useful enough, which I don't find useful.
This is not necessarily a criticism of those
widgets but more of--more a user's point of
view if your app works and nice framework.
So, like, a finance stock widget that you've--that
you basically touch and it speaks the current
stock price is an enormous use, right?
It saves you that effort of content switching
and going to that app and look for that thing.
Talk widget obviously speaks the time.
You know, you don't have to launch the thing.
Great stuff.
I actually find the Gmail a very, very useful.
So, I can actually have in my own screen a
Gmail widget that shows me a particular demo.
And in my mind [INDISTINCT] summarizing the
widget that actually speaks the summaries
of all the--of [INDISTINCT].
It's very nice because one touch you hear
it, you tap it, you have it.
The widget installed are not that useful.
So, videos that shows you the seven books
you have on your bookshelf by showing a little
pixilated image of the spine of the book.
Not too useful.
And because the thing if you started doing
an accessible, speakable version of that.
The way you touch it and speaks the titles
of the seven books.
You might as well launch the thing and go
look at it there.
And, so, on the other hand, a widget that
directly launches a book is very useful because
that's, like, you know, you're reading a book,
you just--you know the process of reading
it.
You pause reading it.
Maybe it's a book you are reading over three
weeks.
Having a video to that book on your home screen
is really useful.
So, yeah.
So, app videos are embedded videos--are actually--absolutely
useful because again you just know what it
does without launching the apps.
So...
>> FERNANDEZ: So, from like a coding perspective,
do you guys have any information about how
that should be done?
Is it the same basically of what we're doing
in the things around the stuff?
>> VIVERETTE: Yeah.
It's...
>> RAMAN: The same--the same thing.
>> VIVERETTE: Same thing.
>> BURKHARDT: That's the same deal.
Add content descriptions always make sure
that you have contentDescriptions.
Always test your apps with accessibility turned
on.
And your eyes close because you'll find out
a lot of short comings.
>> FERNANDEZ: That's right.
All right.
Great.
Anymore questions?
I don't see anything here.
>> Yeah.
I'm going to put Richard back on.
We have actually sound now.
I was able to debug.
So...
>> Yeah.
>> Very good.
>> Awesome.
>> VIVERTTE: Welcome back.
>> RAMAN: Hello Richard.
>> How are you doing sir?
>> RAMAN: Are you all right?
>> FERNANDEZ: Good.
Thank you.
Any question?
>> Yeah.
I'm on a [INDISTINCT] too.
I restarted my browser so that helps.
So, I was kind of curious about any time my
feature comes about.
I work for a company in Malpitas and what
we do is a certification programs.
So, my job is Android full-time and my job
is to be aware of these features, run the
development crew.
And what we're doing particularly interested
in are like the certification that goes around
the device.
So, you implement the feature.
It goes to the carrier or the OEM.
They implement the feature.
How do you--when you make viewer go to show
the features are working properly?
>> RAMAN: So, excessive data or CTS [INDISTINCT]
accessibility along with the other parts of
the platform.
So...
>> Did you say CTS Test?
>> RAMAN: CTS.
Yes.
>> FERNANDEZ: Right.
It's the Compatibility Test Suite.
It's the--an acronym if you need the translation
there.
>> RAMAN: Right.
>> No, that's fine.
I just haven't seen that particular test suite
yet.
>> FERNANDEZ: Okay.
Yeah.
That's--you need to go check out the source.android.com
site and look under the compatibility tab
and you'll find the information about that.
>> Okay.
So, you do have your test suite out there?
I've got all the code of course.
And I'll just go and take a look down in there
and see what you guys are doing.
>> FERNANDEZ: Uh-hmm.
>> Because one of the things that I have to
deal with too is when an arbitrate person
writes an app and they're using it after I'll
be able to tell them whether or not they've
done it right.
>> RAMAN: Right.
>> So...
>> RAMAN: Yeah.
So, with those we don't have test for those
today.
And what the CTS best do is they test what
you ask before which is, you know, a tenure
or a device provider has make Android and
they've implemented it on their device.
How did they know that their platform is complied
and that...
>> Okay.
>> RAMAN: ...what you see it does too.
And as a part of that they also--we also test
for accessibility compliance to make sure
that the accessibility of the platform doesn't
break.
>> Okay.
Perfect.
Those are very useful by the way [INDISTINCT]
up the platform.
Thank you so much for putting those out there.
It's...
>> RAMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> It allows--it literally allows me to do
my job.
>> RAMAN: Do good, useful things with it.
That's why we put it out there.
>> Oh, absolutely.
The hard part I have is getting through all
the code.
I've spent so much time just going through
the code and making adjustments.
I wish I had more time and actually put it
back in.
In fact today, I just signed the contributor
agreement for Google after all these years.
>> FERNANDEZ: All right.
>> So, hopefully you'll be seeing some things.
But, yeah, it's a lot of code to go through.
>> FERNANDEZ: Oh, yeah.
That's great.
But we're glad to have you as a contributor
and keep asking us questions and contribute
it to the--to the site.
We really appreciate it.
>> RAMAN: And to keep you busy we are writing
all codes.
>> Yeah, that's good.
I know.
Now, well, part of the--part of the challenge
with picking your contribution is--to work
on it how do I not duplicate what's already
been down because I don't know what someone
is doing it 2:00 in the morning, you know.
>> FERNANDEZ: Yeah.
>> BURKHARDT Yeah.
>> RAMAN: Yes, you don't need to know.
>> No, there isn't.
>> FERNANDEZ: Yeah.
>> So, that's part of it.
That's part of it.
>> RAMAN: Let's do it.
I think just do it and hope you're doing it
better.
>> VIVERETTE: That's right.
>> FERNANDEZ: Definitely, you want to the
most and do that.
>> RAMAN: And you'll probably...
>> FERNANDEZ: That's a good rule to follow
in our lives.
>> I'm doing a lot of virtual machine work
right now and down in--down in the guts of
doubt right now.
And so, what I'll be looking for is, you have
this virtual machine handle the TalkBack because
you're dealing--there's a native interface
I assume.
>> VIVERETTE: Oh, this is actually a great
time to mention that if you turn on TalkBack
on the emulator...
>> Uh-hmm.
>> VIVERETTE: ...It just works.
So, the emulator has text speech.
>> Okay.
>> VIVERETTE: You may need to install TalkBack--does
TalkBack built in to the emulator now?
>> RAMAN: I don't know.
>> VIVERETTE: You may need to install TalkBack
separately.
>> RAMAN: Uh-hmm.
Yes.
>> FERNANDEZ: Okay.
>> VIVERETTE: That's available also on the
eyes-free project site that we mentioned where
the source code for TalkBack is.
But if you turn on you can use Touch Exploration
by moving your mouse around the screen.
>> Yes.
>> VIVERETTE: You can basically--and actually
that's a great way to test keyboard accessibility.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> VIVERETTE: So, you get a desktop with a
keyboard.
You open up the emulator and you can use the
arrow keys to move through your application.
And that works the same way that a hardware
keyboard would on a device like droid.
>> RAMAN: Alan has mentioned moving the mouse,
let me reticulate that.
The way Touch Exploration is implemented on
Android is using what we call the--[INDISTINCT]
pipeline.
And so, when you move your mouse--point mouse
that generates how it entered and how it exited
events.
And that actually walk the figure as generating
when you're doing Touch Exploration.
>> Okay.
So, who handle...
>> RAMAN: So, I don't know...
>> What part of the OS handles the event--the
actual event?
Is that--does done on the main thread or are
you passing it off to some other service?
>> FERNANDEZ: That's probably a little deeper
than we can go...
>> VIVERETTE: Yeah.
So, I can go into a 30 minutes explanation
of...
>> RAMAN: Yes.
>> No, no, that why I talk about it.
>> VIVERETTE: I will touch the input system.
>> RAMAN: It can be done by looking first
core.
The other floating part if you're playing
with an emulator of--or if, you know, an S2,
you can also play with Bluetooth keyboards.
I actually have a little pocket sized Bluetooth
Keyboard that I sometimes use.
And that keyboard actually has a little touchpad
that access that most.
And you can actually do touch it's relation
using the things.
That's actually very cool.
You can email from your pocket and hold this
keyboard and, you know, Touch Explore your
phone.
That is very interesting.
>> Okay.
I'll go down--I'll go down and look at the
code that would probably answer my question
though.
>> RAMAN: Sounds good.
Yes.
>> FERNANDEZ: Sounds great.
>> RAMAN: Thank you Richard.
>> FERNANDEZ: All right.
>> You're welcome.
Thank you very much.
>> FERNANDEZ: Great.
Yeah.
Thanks for joining us.
And we're just about out of time.
So, we're going to wrap up.
Thanks to Alan and Casey and Raman today for
joining me in telling us all about to how
to make our applications successful.
We'll be posting those resources that we mentioned,
project, the application that were demonstrated
today which includes the upper class for accessibility,
correct?
>> BURKHARDT: That's right.
>> FERNANDEZ: And take a look for that on
our Google+ stream.
And that's it for today.
We'll be in--we'll be here again next week
to take our general questions around Android
development.
So, thanks for joining us.
We'll see you next week.